stop stop stop hurting America okay ben
karlin his producer at the time
apologized to me about it and said you
know John really look like a look like a
jerk it's not the word to use but look
like you know he humiliated himself out
there and I've agreed with that hi I'm
Michael Moynihan with Reason TV and
today we are at the offices of The Daily
Caller and sitting with us is the
editor-in-chief is it that your title
editor among many winner or the Victoria
Cross for gallantry at our chief setter
Ellison
yes sir Tucker tell us a little bit
about the Daily Caller
what you're trying to achieve with the
websites and and just give us a sense of
what your mission is success success is
our mission yeah we're a news
organization we've hired a bunch of
reporters to cover the White House in
the Congress because we feel there's a
big gap in the coverage there are fewer
people covering government at exactly
the time when government is doing more
than it ever has so there's a need we're
not filling that need we're doing our
small part but we're trying what
differentiates this site from say the
Huffington Post I mean why is somebody
going to get easily is it a political
thing as it's like why is Eleva would go
to both okay I mean it's you know there
aren't very many political sites or
primarily political sites out there that
are doing reporting so it's not as if
people are going to choose between us
and the Politico or us in the Huffington
Post I mean we don't really at this
stage have competitors because there
aren't so many people in in the space at
this moment I think 10 years from now
and there are a lot of people doing this
will have competitors but right now the
people are having impost have been
really nice and helpful to us and same
at Politico and TPM and you know we
don't we don't I personally do not share
the politics of Arianna Huffington to
put it mildly
but word I think trying to do similar
things trying to add to the reporting to
the known facts about how the government
is working and other things too looking
around trying to find negative comments
about Daily Caller and didn't find many
but there is a rather an
a little fellow named James Wolcott from
Vanity Fair I'm sure you're familiar
with I thought you would for cat fancy
he does he writes for cat fancy too but
this is what he wrote for Vanity Fair
Tucker's Pringles can I'm not sure I
understand that joke Tucker's Pringles
can deploy other mind nulling devices
such as conceding space to a monotonous
array of white haired guys posed in
front of American flags presenting
boring op-eds their congressional staffs
probably drafted since the evidence of
into individual voices nil the raison
d'être I think that he means the reason
of this site eludes me talk to Haley
right he really wrote I really used the
phrase liaison dental yeah yeah he's
from France so tell us about I mean you
have you do I looked at the site this
morning on the left-hand channel there
you have pea-sized and a lot of them
from people from congressmen senators
yeah I mean we've got some of them from
members of Congress I think our first
day we had a maybe a disproportionate
large number of them absolutely happy to
take interesting opinion pieces from
anyone including whoever this guy is
truly if you've got something
interesting to say you know your
personal appearance or hygiene or
grooming habits or no barrier honestly
it doesn't matter we don't care we're
completely democratic that way it just
so happened that we had a lot of pieces
from members of Congress but you know we
our main goal in that section is to
provide interesting opinions period I
mean that's that's the sole criterion so
they don't always have to agree with my
politics my politics of are so
complicated that I don't even understand
my own politics a lot of the time so
there's certainly no requirement that
people ate my views let's let's talk
about that briefly your politics you are
a fellow at the Cato Institute that's
right you believe I'm a senior fellow
you're a senior fellow at the Cato
Institute so you were the M you're an MC
of the Ron Paul shadow convention was
the you are a libertarian conservative
some hybrid I guess
you guys I really I'm not really quite
good sure I have libertarian instincts
but I also have all kinds of views that
are in conflict with one another you
know for a drug legalization for
instance I mean I know it's hard to
believe that I despise laws that tell
people that they can't do things for
their own good I mean they drive me
crazy seatbelt laws and etc anti-drug
laws on the other hand you know I spent
some time in Amsterdam and I don't want
to I don't want to live in Amsterdam
it's awful
you know it's depressing and so there is
a place where theory bumps up against
reality and I'm not always sure where
that place is but it exists and so you
know does that make me a less
doctrinaire I mean I'm not I guess I'm
not very doctrinaire is the point I'm
making and and I'm certainly willing
especially as I get older to admit that
I I don't really know the answer to some
questions I just mentioned you were the
emcee for the Ron Paul shadow convention
well I know what I think about that yeah
I like Ron Paul and I'm always willing
to do something you know new and
interesting always even if it's
humiliating and stupid you walked out
though I didn't walk out I really like
Ron Paul I know Ron Paul and I think
he's a decent man and I have a lot of
respect for him there were people at the
convention Jesse Ventura namely who got
up and claimed that America or the Jews
or some secret cabal was responsible for
heritage for night yeah for 9/11 and you
know everybody I I have a lot of trouble
judging other people's lunatic political
beliefs I'm not very judgmental believe
it or not at all having been around
crazy political beliefs my whole life
adult life covering them but that's that
was too far from me so he was bad it was
that event it was Ventura is that
specifically and I said I look I I
didn't you know get up at the podium and
say I'm out of here this is too crazy I
didn't you know issue a press release I
didn't tell anybody you know I was with
my friend Matt Leigh bash and and and I
believe Dan Hayes is like a hippie
cameraman for four reason was there I
remember him backstage and I'm from a
great American and great America and I
lay bash said to me - do you know what
they dine he's was interviewing me for
reason and
Laidback comes up and says dear what
they did cetera Jesus I said no he said
blaming you know 9/11 on the Bush
administration or Israel or something
and I said well that's just too much
let's just get here so I told the the
organizer of the event I'm sorry I have
to go I'm not going to tell anybody I
don't want to make a stinker I like Ron
Paul as a person but I don't want to be
associated with that I mean that's too
much you gotta have some standard and
that's mine
if you mentioned your name to people
that aren't sort of deep in the weeds of
politics or inside the beltway people
they will most frequently associate you
with what is the now-infamous jon
stewart appearance well I didn't you
know I didn't get it I'm a writer I
started out as a writer I think of
myself as a writer still even though not
really anymore but but my mind works as
most writers minds do I'm sort of
literal in certain ways I didn't even
realize this about myself and so I
evaluate arguments pretty much on their
own terms it's got a better argument and
I thought and I and I've had bad
arguments before and I know when I've
lost a debate and I have lost that's for
sure but I didn't lose that debate I
thought his art his argument was stupid
he's not stupid he's talented but I
thought what he said was ridiculous it
didn't mean it was just air it didn't
mean anything to me at all and still
doesn't and so I didn't really get that
I was perceived to have lost it didn't
even really occur to me
I thought he in fact hid ben karlin his
producer at the time apologized to me
about it and said you know John really
look like a look like a jerk it's not
the word to use but look like you know
he humiliated himself out there and I've
agreed with that but it became clear in
the next couple weeks and I don't ever
Google myself for paying a lot of
attention to that stuff but it became
clear that the consensus was I had been
beaten by Jon Stewart and I at some
point maybe a year or so later stepped
back and realized well Jon Stewart's
just more famous and more popular than I
am I mean that's just true I'm much more
successful than I am so you know this is
America and majority rules and the more
popular guy wins almost a man no matter
what he says I'm not mad about it it
hasn't affected my life at all really or
maybe it has robbed
care to think about how but no I think
he won because he's more popular than I
I mean it was also at a time and tell me
if I'm wrong about this where there is a
sort of building anger against the Bush
administration that's right or in you
who were opposed to the Iraq war correct
I was the most about Korea where this
sort of Jon Stewart slapping around the
yeah wing media you hadn't even thought
about that are the conservative on the
panel because who it was it was you who
else was on kala kala kalah who was also
slapped around a little bit and that ya
know came to your defense but you were
the person that in the end it was Tucker
Carlson versus you see I'm not very
self-aware at all so what she just said
has actually never occurred to me
believe it or not until right now but I
think there's probably some truth in
that I think I you know I didn't vote
for Bush I didn't I didn't like Bush I
thought that Bush well I know Bush and I
actually I've always liked him
personally to some extent
he's certainly charming guy but I
thought he was a crummy president I
thought that from the very beginning I
didn't like his behavior on 9/11 fleeing
from Washington I I criticized him
throughout the whole eight years and
from the right by the way from the
libertarian right Tucker thank you thank
you Michael I appreciate